hello everyone this is Game two of the
2003 Kasparov versus Fritz x3d match
I've already shown you game number three
that the Garry Kasparov won that
beautiful positional masterpiece but
this is Game two and well here cuz power
played an excellent game but in time
trouble he may he made a pretty big
blunder and it cost him the game so for
its extra Diaz white and Kasparov is
black let's see the game we have E 4 E 5
Knight to f3 and Knight to c6 and Bishop
to b5 the were Lopez and the cusp arm
goes for the Berlin Knight to f6 and
kramnik played a match against Fritz in
2002 and he also managed to draw using
the Berlin defence and also Kramnik used
it in his World Championship match
against Garry Kasparov with a great
success but Fritz in this position plays
pawn to d3
he doesn't allow the main line which
occurs after castling and night catchers
on e4 d4 Knight to d6 Bishop captures c6
d capture c6 and RD captures on e5
Knight to a5 Queen captures and e8 and
King captures and e8 so Fritz and the
fritz team decide that they don't want
this
well simplification in the game so after
Knight f6 d3 is played Kaspar goes for
d6 so we have c3 g6 castles Bishop to g7
Knight B to d2
Kasparov castles rook to e1 rook to e8
and now d4 okay Bishop to d7 d5 grabbing
some more space in the center nicely 7
Bishop captures on b7 and Queen and
sorry nice capture son d7 and a for
Chris Barber goes for h6 a5 a6 and B 4
and ok Fritz decided to play on the
Queen side and cause power replies with
a counter in the center so he plays f5
I'm going for that e4 pawn we have c4
and now Knight to f6 Bishop to b2 and
now Queen to d7
Rock the b1 and the g5 preparing g4 and
f4 so Fritz captures a captures on f5
Queen captures on f5 and out nights to
f1 preparing 93 or 93 Kasparov goes a
queen to h7 preparing freeing dead at 5
square for the knight Knight 3 to d2
because power goes Knight to f5 Knight
e4 Knight captures any for rook captures
on e4 and h5 and it seems like a pretty
good position for Kasparov black is
definitely more active his King is a bit
bit drafty here but the position is took
Apsara favored Queen to d3 and we have
worked f8 rook BTE one rook the f7
Kasparov is preparing to double up on
the F file a rook e1 to e2 g4 Queen to
b3 rook a to f8 we have c5 Queen to g6
now C capture Sun b6 c captures on d6 +
b5 and ok it seems that Fritz broke
through on the Queen side a cat zombie v
Queen captures on b5 but well it's not
that easy to grab this pawn on b7 so
Bishop 286 by Kasparov now Queen to b6
King to h7 Queen to b4
we have rocked g7 and well in this
position what Kasparov is doing well
he's doing very nice you could even say
that he is better but he's he's under a
lot of time pressure and well he should
probably continue with the move like
rook to c8 and then maybe transfer the
game on the C file but due to time
tropical power played rock the g7 and he
allows such a simple move that well that
loses him the game in this position
Fritz x3d played rukka captures on e5
really a simple tactic after we captured
a rook you lose the road on f8 so but
capturing Brooke is
the best move Kaspar captured Queen
captures on f8 was played nice the d4
attacking the rook but well now he's up
upon Bishop captures he captures and
rook to e8 threatening Queen h8
checkmate eruptive J defending Queen to
e7 we'll check her up to g7 and now
Queen to e8 threatening again a rock tha
checkmate now rocked back to g8 and now
Queen - Queen to d7 check and in this
position Garry Kasparov resigned the
game because well after a move like
Bishop to g7 simply exchange rooks row
captures King captures and the Queen
capture some b7 and this as well
impossible to play for black this a pawn
is just three squares from the screen a
queening point for example d3 you can't
really even push the pawn further than
d3 because night is covering d2 and if
you push d3 you're also blocking your
own queen from entering the game so but
other than d3 what do you play well
you don't play anything since there's
nothing to play and in this position
because Paro resigned if you haven't
seen the game 3 work as part of one
against the frits x3d it will be
available right here in my previous
videos so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon